we r EP bird we are known as the coke
and mentos guys and we have a new video
we put our first coke and mentos video
online at EP berg four years ago
instantly we're going okay so now we got
to do something else now we got to come
up with something to top that what else
can we do with coke and mentos we're
getting skateboards out we're strapping
bottles on sodium two skateboards and
putting bottles on and making like sort
of right angle turns in the jet so that
it shoots out the back what we realized
is that is that a steam engine does not
just shoot steam out of the back of the
locomotive the key insight was to use a
piston system that was a secret we
settled on this six-foot long sleeve and
this six-foot long piston we take an old
utility trailer and we took the front
end of a bicycle and we well got another
part and put them together all the
reactions pushing the piston out and the
piston is backed up against a really
heavy wall which then pushes everything
in the vehicle and Fritz forward first
time we tested that the wall moved so
what you see in the video we used a
3,000 pound wall so we have loaded up
this vehicle with a hundred and eight
bottles of coke zero we drop 648 Mentos
in to those 108 bottles simultaneously
if you look at our classic internet
video experiment number 137 all of that
power is in this rocket car all released
at the exact same tells simultaneously
the whole vehicle with soda and
everything weighs about 900 pounds we're
hitting about 18 19 20 miles an hour so
what we have to do is we have to prepare
108 nozzles then we have to run 108
pieces of string from these 108 clips
and not tangle them which is no mean yet
um those 108 strings go to six
carabiners so six carabiners are
attached to two poles those two kohls
get pulled from the front of the vehicle
to the back that simultaneously releases
all of the Mentos we actually got an
amazing director for this video we were
flabbergasted he volunteered to do it
because he just thought the whole idea
was cool Rob Cohen who was the guy that
directed The Fast and the Furious and a
bunch of other stuff we managed to set a
new speed and distance record for a Coke
Zero and mentos powered vehicle with a
human pilot of 221 our crew started
calling this video the fizzy and the
Furious